Today, I'm walking my brother through
the exact strategy I use to actually
take trades in the market. But, instead
of just explaining it, we're breaking
down real trade examples step-by-step.
You're going to see how I read price
action, identify key levels, and wait
[music] for confirmation before
entering. It's not guessing, it's not
predicting, because the truth is most
beginners don't lose because they lack
trading knowledge or strategy patterns.
They lose because they're doing too much
too fast. So, in this video, we're
simplifying everything, [music] focusing
on one repeatable system, how the market
actually moves, and how to execute with
confidence. If you follow along, you'll
start to see the market the way I do
when I'm trading live every [music]
single morning. So, let's walk through
it and start taking trades the right
way. Okay, so
>> Episode 3.
>> [laughter]
>> Um I mean, I guess first thing is like
this week we want to try and get you
ready for trading. Yeah, so I guess we
want to try and get you set up with like
the indicators I use or just the quality
of life things for NinjaTrader I use,
and then
um
we can talk more about like actually
entering in trades and how to execute
that stuff. And we can go over the
strategy a little bit. Like I have this
PDF that I made that I can send to you
that kind of just has like a nice like
quick overview of each of the like five
steps.
Um six steps, I guess, if you count
trade management. And so, I can send
that to you and anyone else who wants
that. I can put that in the description
below of the video. From what I
understand is like you have a rough idea
of the strategy. And I think talking
about Like we can talk about some
examples. Like today and yesterday had
great examples and some um
trades I took last week and kind of talk
about those and we'll probably really
hash out Yeah, I'm definitely going to
I'm getting more to the point where like
I can I can figure out where kind of the
the first two things are happening but
it seems to be getting into a zone of
something seems like it could happen
here but then I'm not quite sure what
I'm looking for to tell me what's going
to happen or what I should be
specifically looking for. Yeah, that
makes sense. You know, and I guess we
could just talk about
um
I'm just thinking like maybe it makes
more sense to do like give you the
indicators and that kind of set up later
and we can talk about kind of the trade
setup that happened this morning and
some just some chart examples. You were
watching the market this morning. What
did you you know, kind of we had this
spot on where the market opened up here,
you know, at 9:30
>> Yeah. and then we came down to this
15-minute timing
um and kind of the levels I was looking
at into today was just kind of this
range we had. Yeah, those those are the
same two that I identified and was
looking at and then I had some other
larger Oh, gosh, wrong button. Some like
zoomed out ones. Yeah, zoomed out of
like generally the market's been going
up and having upward pressure but
obviously for the last what is it day or
so it's been in that little channel.
This is just overnight. Market closed. I
mean, this is the overnight closed line
right here.
>> Yeah. Okay. But this is definitely like
a common thing where a lot of times like
the market will have some spike up and
then like it'll be in this channel. I
saw it kind of going along this channel
and so I was thinking it's probably
going to do something where it's just
keep bouncing in between the two. Mhm.
Um and so then we got into that spot
that you were looking at and I think I
was looking at it more on
um
NQ because it was just down closer to
the resistance Yeah. the support Yeah.
So, I was looking at it there um and so
here [clears throat] I saw I was like,
okay, it's done one little bounce and
then the next but the next bounce is
lower rather than higher. Yeah. Um
so I didn't quite see something super
nice to like get in on um and you're
obviously looking for it to break that
trend. And so then it like kind of broke
it and just went straight up and I was
maybe hoping that it would do a little
like head shoulders pattern, but instead
just ripped up. Yeah, a kind of pull
back here. Yeah, and then I saw you
posted something about what it was
looking like on the ES and I was like,
"That's much more clear of a like comes
down and then goes up." Yeah, like the
ES had much more of Yeah, like a head
and shoulders where it had a spike here
and then it made a new low. Yeah. And
then instead of I would I think this
where Nasdaq made a new low like you're
saying Yeah.
>> the
Yeah. And so like I I wasn't trading
this morning really, but yeah, getting
in above kind of above here would have
been where I would have got in cuz it's
Yeah, I had a query on that. Yeah, I had
a query on that.
Yeah, cuz you're looking at to break
that long Yeah.
>> candle or wick, right?
>> Yeah, the high of this candle. Like the
problem is like it's not a It's not a
It's a little more congested of a
bottom. Like it's not like a nice clean
where it's like, "Okay, you see it pull
back here and then you're like, okay,
well when it breaks this I'm going to
get hot get in." Yeah.
>> Like it's still doing that here the
price, but it's definitely very
condensed. It's almost like it did it
all in that It's more It's like it's
doing like this and then you're like,
"Okay, well that's I'll get in when it
breaks that essentially." Cuz it still
kind of does a little bit of a pull back
and I think this the idea is like it's
still showing you that the downtrend is
slowing down and it's like losing
momentum, you know, cuz it's we had big
spike here, big spike lower here that
made a new low and then it just kind of
instead of you you'd think there would
be follow through with this bearish
candle right here because it you know,
it's just a big bearish candlestick so
you'd assume, "Okay, the next few
candles would go down." But instead like
it does another choppy candle and then
it makes a new low by like one tick. And
so then it's like, "Okay, well, if it
reverses all the way up here, that's
going to be pretty strong." But it's
probably going to keep going.
[clears throat] It doesn't like get as
far down as the Nasdaq did. Like the
Nasdaq did It went all the way down to
the resistance floor. Yeah, where is it?
Yeah. Like it came down and like tested
it much better. And like here it it
actually broke it on the 5-minute. So it
did a minor breakout, but like, you
know, if you think about it big picture,
it's like, "Okay, it's still coming down
to this low area." Yeah.
>> Like really like having your box like
that. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> you know, what I'm saying?
>> totally fine. And so it's like it didn't
really like miss that, you know, and
even if you just think about, "Okay,
well, it came down to where this
originally bounced." Yeah. And then it
kind of exploded.
>> I've had a couple of the spots where it
kind of gets down and does that little
consolidation [clears throat] thing. I
don't have a good indication or gut read
on whether that's just a consolidation
and then it keeps going lower or whether
it's a consolidation and keeps going
higher. Like I've got it down that
that's a like a decision point for going
one way or the other, but
>> Yeah. I think for me here, so like the
biggest thing with this common pattern
where the market, you know, is in like
an uptrend and then it does this
overnight range that you're going into
in the market. I often like think,
"Okay, unlikely that the market stays in
this during the day because it's such a
small range. It's just overnight, you
know, it's These are These are
definitely minor levels. They're not big
like you know, levels off of a 15-minute
chart, but I still think they're
important cuz they can just because
trade on a 1-minute chart and if the
swings are big enough, they can still
produce a good trade. Um
the main thing is I generally think of,
"Okay, well, I just want to see how it
reacts to these zones. Um like if it
comes down here, is it going to bounce
and I can get a swing? Or is it going to
come down here, bounce, and then break,
and the move for the day is going to go
lower, you know? Yeah. Um and I think a
big thing is like, okay, the big uptrend
we're in an uptrend right now. And so,
for me, that puts my bias more of, you
know, even if the read or I'm a little
less confident in reading into the
candlesticks here of having a clear
signal, I'm going to say, well, I think
my bias is more to the upside because
it's likely we do a fake lower, and
then, you know, break to the highs and
potentially trend the rest of the day.
Versus
>> Okay. if it came up here betting that
it's going to go short, I think that's a
weaker of a play because again, you
know, the big picture is the market's
bullish. Yeah. Like in the big picture,
this is kind of like a consolidation,
and then you keep going up. Yeah, and so
>> going up. Yeah, so even though, you
know, on a 1-minute you're taking a
reversal trade right here, your really
big picture, you know, you're just
buying a pullback that you're expecting
to continue higher. Yeah, cuz overall,
you're think about the big trend. Yeah.
And, you know, yeah. Yeah, go ahead.
Maybe something that would be helpful,
[clears throat] and that I had a
question on from last week, was could
you kind of talk through about market
activity over the day of like cuz it
always seems like it starts off really
energetic, and then kind of slowly slows
down over the rest of the day. And is
that a fair assessment or Yeah, I mean,
I think that's why I only stick to that
it really like the first 30 to an hour
minutes to an hour just because
pretty much when the market opens,
there's almost always volatility, or
that's on average, that's the highest
amount of volatility in the day. Yeah.
Um or or volume, which would create
volatility. And then, as the day goes
on, it's just it's way less likely to
Things just happen slower. Yeah, things
do happen slower because the volume
volume has gone down. And like today was
a great example. Like we had great
swings in the morning and even here
there was like funky swings. But as time
goes on a lot of the time is it just
starts to dwindle and like this
volatility gets reduced and reduced and
reduced. And even like here, you know,
like it it made a swing like all the way
to the downside. It's like it's trading
in this is like really almost
impossible, I find. Or it's just not as
consistent. Yeah, it's I just find it
not as consistent consistent. And then
also for me just the trading, you know,
you can come in, capture, or be
available and ready to take a trade
during the times when there's really
high volatility on average. Cuz again,
like you have to think about okay, can I
do this every single day, you know? Uh
Yeah. And I find it way easier to focus
on this beginning part of the day that
often has volatility and then just leave
and not even think about trying to wait
for this cuz a lot of times it's like
I just get so bored even sitting and
watching this for an hour or like 2
hours, you know, it's like some days
you'll have crazy movement the whole
day, but it's so rare that on average
it's just you're just going to get so
bored and drained and and
>> going to burn yourself out. Yeah, and
you're just going to burn yourself out
and just And when you're burned out and
like you're not focused in trading,
you're just going to make mistakes.
Yeah. Now, something I definitely like
about your strategy is that you can kind
of sit down and do it for like an hour,
hour and a half in the morning
essentially before anything else happens
because at least on the West Coast it's
opens at 6:30 in the morning. Yeah. It's
a early morning, but it's okay.
>> Nothing else is happening at 6:30 in the
morning. So after it went through this
whole upwards, then I was watching it
through here. And to me it was like,
"Okay, it's made kind of I guess the way
I've been thinking about this is I've
been looking for like head and
shoulders." And so I'm like, "Okay,
there's shoulder one. Now I'm or like
bounce one, now I'm looking for a second
bounce and it kind of does that and then
it just pukes lower. Yeah. And then like
immediately comes back up. Um and it's
like, okay, it's I think ultimately it
kind of forms like a something that
looks a little bit like a head and
shoulders. Um
but it's also just like over such a long
period of time.
Um and maybe that's like an acceptable
period of time and I just don't know
what I'm looking for, which is
completely accurate. Yeah, so there's a
couple things here. One, for me, when
like one swing happens like this, I find
it rare that another swing happens.
>> Um it can and so like I was definitely
paying attention to this too cuz I I
still thought there was potential. You
know, I thought there was potential for
the market to, you know, if it comes
down to here and it breaks lower, you
know, it's like that's a big trade.
Yeah. Um and so being open-minded to
that. And so and it was a this was a
super fast move up and I would say
unhealthy move that had reason to give
up and like you're saying, like I
wouldn't want to short here or even like
You know, sometimes I'll just look for a
a high and then a lower high and then go
lower and I won't even it won't set up
really a full head and shoulders. Yeah.
But like this is something that I've
realized that you don't want to get in
on. Like you don't want to just put an
order down here, you know, expecting it
to break this chop range and then, you
know, get in if it does because often
this can like, you know, it can break
lower and push higher. Um especially on
a day like today when the biased, at
least my read was like, okay, major
uptrend.
Like I think we could just be it's more
likely that this just continues to trend
higher. Um
but, you know, when it had this big
crazy candlestick that then failed back
in and I think broke this little minor
support here. Like, you know, once you
start I think reading into kind of the
candlesticks there and the the more
micro patterns, I think it's really
opens up the door to take a trade to the
low side. Okay. Um the problem is
obviously this candlestick is huge and
I'm not going to just put in an order
below this level and get in short there.
Um again, like I I I still same
philosophy of like I want to see that
head and shoulders, that lower high
happen because in these instances, like
you can have these big candlesticks that
just all of a sudden rip lower and then
like reverse. Yeah, cuz it in of itself
is a pretty unhealthy move. Yeah. I
guess one of the things I've been
semi struggling with is letting the
market tell me what's happening versus
trying to predict what's going to
happen. And so essentially like how many
candlesticks do I need to let it and
maybe it's some of just where I am right
now. I'm just like I need like letting
several candlesticks form for me to be
like, "Okay, well, now it's it's
reversing. It's going down or it's
ripping up." versus like trying to
predict that and be Um yeah, I think
some of that just comes with time cuz
it's and sometimes, you know, you just
have a bias and you're wrong. Like it's
okay. Yeah. Or it's like it's just the
market. Like in this today, it's like
the market did do this crazy move and
then punch back up and then punch back
down and when it starts to So, for me
for this trade, I actually I would have
liked the short if it cuz I think this
big candlestick here could be like the
the start of a huge sell-off. Like it is
crazy momentum and with the volatility
the market's had recently, too. But the
thing is it's like I do want to see kind
of what I don't want to just get in
short right below the candlestick
because that's
>> Yeah. Often these candlesticks can just
whip you out kind of like it actually
did. I'd want to see essentially what I
was looking for was again, like looking
at more of the structure and where
reasonable market trends and stuff would
happen. Like here is like kind of this
previous support. And so I'm thinking,
"Okay, it broke that. I want to see it
come up here, test it, and fail." Cuz to
me that's like showing you kind of that
stair-step pattern down. Yeah. And it
breaking, you know, a structural logical
thing you can read and see. Um and so if
it did that, I would have gotten short
below this. Yeah. So you're essentially
you're looking for it to re-break that
downward momentum, essentially
confirming it. Yes.
>> Cuz right now it said, "All right, we
weren't sure about going up. We puked
lower, and then you want to see it come
up and be like test [clears throat] that
level, not go through it, essentially
confirm that it doesn't have upward
pressure, and then actually break
through that low, and then you would get
in." Yeah. I mean, even here when it
made So it's like, you know, here it
broke up, but even here when it made
this, like I was interested in getting
in short here after this push down, but
again like I needed it to come up here
like do it like a little 50% pullback of
this big candlestick, and then break the
low. I guess I'm thinking of it like
right-hand shoulder. You're looking for
it to come up, show that it wants to go
down, kind of pull back a little bit to
confirm, and then actually push down
through. Okay. Um I I mean, I think not
always, but like in this case because
this is already after it's like, "Okay,
here's the big candlestick that failed."
You know, it's it's starting to kind of
act weird. And kind of like you're
saying like um
once it starts to do this over too long,
like I think, you know, the good entry
would have been here after this big push
lower, but because that didn't work out,
it's like, "Okay, now it's starting to
And this is almost like 30-minute time
frame. Yeah, like since it's been it's
starting to chop basically for like 30
minutes, and so it's like it just gets
to the point where it's like it and it's
past, you know, the the kind of 10:00
reversal time
um and it's already done like one swing
in the day. It just starts to get to,
you know, I just get to the idea where
I'm like, "Uh I'm not really
interested." One thing or two, I didn't
really notice this. I don't really
notice this very often, but it was
exactly at 7,000. And so that's kind of
a big psychological level that a lot of
times can cause a little chop or or
resistance or support depending on um
where things are at. Interesting. How
often are you then paying attention or
thinking about the like 11:00 a.m.
potential point?
>> I pretty much never do it. Okay. Just
cuz like I, you know, again that that
requires me to stay another hour versus
just focusing on, "Okay, what's my read
in the first 30 minutes?" Trading based
on that.
>> seem like it's setting up. Yeah. Yeah,
and then, you know, I feel like it opens
the door up for well, you know, you're
trading longer so you're more tired so
you're going to make a worse decision.
And then also like, oh, if you missed a
good trade in the morning, you might try
and force something. Yeah. Um which I've
definitely
>> like, "Oh, I've been I've been putting a
bunch of work in. I should be able to
get a trade." Or like, "I need to make a
trade to make this time that I've just
put in pay off." Versus just seeing if
something's happening. If it's not, move
on. If it is, perfect. Yeah. That's why
I I I feel bad about it sometimes
getting off that fast, especially if
it's like I'm in my chat room or
whatever, but it's like that's what I'm
doing. Like I'm this is my strategy. I'm
sticking to it. Like I that's where I
find the best trades for me and what
works for me. And so it's Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, it's interesting I mean, this kind
of tangent from what we're talking
about, but just like in the chat room,
it seems like there's a bunch of people
who trade similar stuff, but slightly
different things or at least put more
trades in and have some like additional
little I don't know if they're
indicators or what, but other things of
bits of information they're paying
attention to. Yeah. I mean, you know,
everyone just kind of makes it their
own, adds their own variation. Like
someone was talking about the other day
like, "Oh, well, what about um
you know, if you see this happen and you
look you think that it's not going to go
down, what about taking this as a buying
opportunity to go higher?" You know,
like instead of it if the reversal you
know, with the idea of "Oh, if the
reversal's going to fail, like why not
take take the continuation trade?"
Because you know, most likely you're at
this inflection point where it's going
to choose a direction. Yeah. And if it
didn't go down, why not choose up? Yeah,
and I think it can work, but you know,
you can also have days like this where
it's you just get chopped out either
direction and I think it opens the door
for you're adding on a second decision
of even though it seems like it should
be simple in theory and practice, it's I
feel like instead of you know, for me
it's okay, it's coming up to here. It's
showing signs that I don't want to
short, so I'm just going to be done
versus okay, it's showing signs that it
don't doesn't want to short. Now I have
to think about all the signs to go long.
Um and again, like it can I think it can
just complicate things and and sometimes
you can think "Oh, well, I'm seeing
signs to go long, so I'm not going to
take the short." And then you actually
miss the short. Um
and you're like, "Oh, I'm an idiot. You
know, I should have just sat you know,
again, it's Yeah. It's trying to just
simplify things to like almost the
dumbest amount of level of strategy so
then you can't mess it up as much with
your mind being stupid and you trying to
just complicate things.
>> overcomplicate it. Yeah, cuz I I
literally
>> Which seems like it'd be so easy to do.
That's really like what messes people up
with trading is they just overthink
things when it's like the hardest part
is just keeping it as simple as
possible. Yeah, it's been it's been
tempting to try and like figure out some
of the acronyms and other things that
people are using to trade in the chatter
and I'm just like, "Nope, I will skip
that. I have other things I'm trying to
learn and do, so I will stick to stick
to Riley's method." Yeah, cuz it's just
the thought of like, oh, well,
logically, if I learn something else,
shouldn't that make me better or make my
win rate better? And it's like it just
it just doesn't necessarily. It's the
same thing with like, oh, well, trying
to add on taking continuation trades.
It's like, oh, well, shouldn't that make
me more money cuz now I'm taking twice
the amount of trades potentially. And
it's like, no, not necessarily.
>> really interesting in my like
one of my my classes, the professor was
like an old like professional trader,
but he was he was going through he was
like, yeah, there's all these variables
you can bring in to help track different
components and everything like that to
try and get a better guess, but like
ultimately it came down to like three
variables that had the highest
likelihood of like
like momentum was one of them. I was
like, yeah, most of the time momentum
wins. Like you can include everything
else, but most of the time it's going to
be momentum. Uh okay, so this was like
the market was kind of here. I think it
opened it actually opened up here, but
pretty much just sold off. Yeah. But the
idea was it had a huge rip the day
before um and just because the market
was volatile, you know, my thought was
like, okay, well, we might just rip this
back lower and give this move back up.
Go that this is on a 15-minute chart.
And then going into a smaller chart,
um
you know, it kind of it opened up here
and kind of just sold off. Um and so
there wasn't really there wasn't a spot
to get in short, which I would say was
the better read or or better I guess
higher chance of a move just with like,
you know, thinking about Yeah, grabbing
it on the way down. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um and so, you know, it kind of
just kept selling off, sold past off
past the 10:00 reversal time, and then
kind of just started to sit here for a
while. Yeah, went to a little like
sideways channel almost. Uh and so my
thought process on this was, well, we
did have a big sell-off. We could give
this move back up that it's had.
Um
And so I was I think one mistake I did
was I was trading way longer than I
should have. Like once it kind of went
into this chop, I think it's more likely
that, you know, usually these unhealthy
trends, like we the trade we were
talking about this morning is like they
snap back quickly, right? And so I mean
almost exactly like this morning on the
flip side is it just started to kind of
doing a volatile back and forth.
Um
But like, you know, potential reversal
spots I was looking at was my thinking
was, "Okay, well, my my target for the
way down would be this." Like it
essentially giving back these this spike
up it had. And so I would think that,
"Okay, when it hits this, it might
reverse." Um or like here's some kind of
gap that it filled. Um there was like
this little gap here between when the
market closed one day and opened.
Sometimes those can be zones as well.
Yeah, I think that was over the weekend.
Yeah, I think you're right. Um
And so, you know, that's kind of what I
was looking for. Then also, like you
kind of mentioned earlier, the 11:00
reversal timing of thinking, "Okay,
well, maybe this will reverse at kind of
11:00 and we'll start to get some
movement up." Especially since it's kind
of has shown a slow in momentum here.
And so I actually jumped in on a long
right here. Cuz the whole time I was
kind of watching this, I was thinking,
"Okay, I want to see it make a higher
high." Like it made a higher low here,
but I didn't get long because I wanted
to see it make a key you know, cuz in a
spot like this I want more confirmation
because it's more likely it just keeps
going down, you know, every time it
makes a new high, it's lower and lower.
And so I think confirmation of the
changing that is when it kind of breaks
this. And so like it broke this, pulled
back, and then actually it kind of held
this, which I thought was a good sign.
Kind of what we were talking about
earlier of like coming back to the
previous swing and Has to see if it
wants to go low. Yeah, now realizing
okay, that's support. So, I actually
bought in at the high this candlestick.
Um and then it, you know, barely made a
new high and then kind of reversed lower
from there.
Um and I I think like this is a good
read for like the trend potentially
shifting. But, big picture like kind of
in hindsight a little bit for me was my
mistakes were staying too long and then
also I do have a pretty common rule that
I follow is
uh if it's trended down like that long
and that like this is a huge sell-off
actually from here to here. Even though,
you know, it fits on my screen. Like
this is pretty much 50 points um which
in the ES is like a huge move. And so,
but you know, I like going off of here,
right? Like this is a huge move really
fast. Yeah. Um that has a lot of
momentum and and there is the idea of
like oh, it is unhealthy. But, the same
idea with this move up being unhealthy
the day before, like I I didn't even
think about trying to bet this to the
short side with the idea that okay,
well, more likely these kind of moves
it's just trucking up. Yeah. Yeah, it's
well, it's got so much momentum and it
almost needs overnight to
work off and then it'll flip. Um I think
it literally our last session we were
talking about this. Yeah, we were.
>> And I was like oh, it probably is going
to either reverse tomorrow or, you know,
maybe midday or the next day. Um
which is kind of funny now looking at
that in hindsight how it just ripped the
next day. So, it's like usually it takes
something like that and even here it's
like okay, it's sold off the whole day.
It had a little bit of a bounce into the
end of the day just cuz it got so
overextended. But, you know, then it it
the major trend kind of came into play
and and it did like kind of come back
50% of this move. Yeah. Which is like a
healthy pullback in the trend before it
continues lower big picture. Yeah. No, I
think I think cuz at that same spot that
you got in, I was looking and just had
some notes down that were like, "Oh,
this looks like a good spot." Like it's
broken that little channel, so it's
changing trends. And especially when
like I think my chart was probably
zoomed in even a little bit more to
cover essentially, I don't know, call
like 5:30 towards like 8:30 onwards. And
so in this, it doesn't look like too
crazy of a down or anything like that.
It looks much more plausible that like,
"Oh, yeah, it can looks like a great
spot for a reversal." Yeah, and
I I mean it could it could have totally
done like, you know, it's like it
totally could have, but I feel like in
my it's like that's where it's the good
lesson of um getting too sucked into the
smaller time frame and getting into the
1-minute chart.
>> Yeah. When if you just glance at the
bigger picture, you know, uh uh I mean I
think it was pretty much if I try and
make sure I get the the pricing right on
this, it was pretty much here. And it's
like that is you know, for me like
that's in the middle of the main range.
Like there's no Like even though it's
giving this move back up as a good
target, that's a target for a trade
you're in. I don't use that as
necessarily a level. Yeah. And so like
to me there's just no reason to bet long
there um in hindsight and and really
reading what the market's telling you,
you know? And so it's hard sometimes to,
you know, you make mistakes. So and
that's part of trading. Like you just
you get sucked in or or you stay too
long. That's why, you know, that's why I
don't like to stay long is cuz I like a
long period of time trading cuz it's
like it gives me way more likely to just
get sucked in and FOMO into something or
just make a bad decision like that.
Yeah. Yeah, something I think I wrote
down either that day or the next was
like, "Don't think in terms of I want it
to blank. Think in terms of let's see if
it does blank." So rather than being
like, "Okay, I want it to give me
another little bounce or another top. I
want it to do this." Just be like, let's
see if this happens. Because I think if
they're like, I want it to, I'm
I feel like I'm more likely trying to
read it or make it happen. I'm like,
"Ooh, that looks like maybe that's my
bounce. Or maybe that's this." Rather
than just, did it actually do that?
You're just adding bias onto what's
happening. Another thing I think, too,
is like trying to think of like for this
example of like, "Okay, as it's coming
down to this area, you know, it's like,
okay, it's still clearly in a move down.
It's still making lower lows and lower
highs, but we're near a zone. You know,
like we're near Yeah.
>> in the sense of like, I know there's
potential coming soon, like you're
saying. And so, instead of being like,
"Oh, I want it to do this." Another
thing I think about is like,
to get in a trade, what would I want to
see? You know, it's like it's not like I
want it to do this or I need it to do
this. It's more of like, "I'm only going
to get in if it does blank" kind of
thing, versus
Yeah.
>> mean, trying to essentially the main
idea is trying to have it pre-planned
out of what you want to see to execute
your plan. And so, you're waiting for
the market to come to your already
figured out idea, versus, "Oh, I'm just
kind of sitting here watching it all of
a sudden." And then, "Oh, shoot, it you
know, it did this big candlestick here.
I better just jump in long." And you
know, bet that it's going to go higher.
>> Hope, yeah. Cuz that just, you know, you
don't want to be reactionary to the
market, right? No. What do you How do
you trade around when it seems like the
market, obviously it's not hitting new
lows, but when it's hitting like lows
that it hasn't been at for a while? I
think we kind of talked about this last
time, at least with highs. Yeah. Yeah,
like here in this downtrend, like we
broke this big level, and then so it's
like, okay, well, there's I don't really
have a, you know, even if I scroll back
on a daily chart or something, like
there's no
>> Yeah. There's nothing for a long time,
yeah.
>> It's kind of just like, yeah, you just
got to wait. And
>> Yeah. I mean, if it once it puts this
in, like even here, I'll say, "Okay,
I'll draw a level here and see." When it
comes down here, I'll look for it to
react on this cuz it's like, "Okay,
well, maybe it double bottoms and I can
get like a little trade right here."
Yeah.
But then otherwise, yeah, it's just kind
of waiting cuz it it doesn't happen very
often, at least in the market conditions
we're right now. But when it does, like
it, you know, it just even with this,
like if this was an uptrend into new
all-time highs, and you did would you
know, you would just be saying, "Okay,
well, there's, you know, this high that
it's pulled back from. I'm going to see
how it reacted there." And then it it
does this, right? If the market opened
up here, and then it moves along, and
you say, "Okay, well, there's a new high
I put in. I'm going to do a double top
and then put in a level there." And then
as time goes on, you know, I'd only draw
this about after this kind of stuff
here.
>> Yeah. And then same thing. I'm like,
"Okay, well, it's got this, you know,
like this morning, right? Had this like
little bracket." And so you go into the
day with that now, but that's just how
you, you know, over time would update
your levels and then, you know, delete
them. Or you could even say, "Well, this
even matched with that high." Looking
back on it. I mean, yeah, we essentially
talked about it on the high side. And
also it's very back back to that what we
were just talking about of the like, "I
want it to I want to trade in this
rather than just let's let's wait for
everything to happen and unfold in front
of us." Yeah. Cool. I guess there's this
trade from last week, too, that I
entered that we could briefly talk
about. Oh, yeah. Yeah. So this is when
the market was pretty much right here. I
think it opened up like this. And so
like we were still kind of in a
downtrend, and so the thought was like
once it kind of got up to here, I think
this is kind of where the the short was.
There was it did kind of break this, but
my thought was like, "Okay, well, we've
kind of come up to here." And maybe this
is, you know, me not sometimes being a
little aggressive about the levels I
draw.
Um
But thinking, "Okay, well, I had this
move down."
>> What do you mean by that? Um I think
maybe looking for levels in spots where
Okay. it's not as clean, you know, like
like quick example is here for this one.
It's like, okay, we had the sell-off
here and we've given up that move kind
of exactly like that. That last loss I
did was like, okay, well, here's a
target for this move, but it doesn't
necessarily mean it's a good spot to
short. Yeah. Um you know, like like I
was talking about over here as it came
down here and like using this as a
target, it's not necessarily a good
shot. Like it's basically in the middle
of this range. Yeah.
>> Betting this. It's kind of same thing
here of like, well, it's given this move
back up, but big picture it's kind of
like there's just some gerbil garble
here whatever. Like there's not clean
swings. Versus like, you know, today
this morning, right? Like there's this
is clean.
>> clear, yeah. I feel like this is the
most clear that I've seen. Yeah, like
these were clean. Um and so that's where
it's like again,
Like the levels are clean.
>> been the most clear that I've seen.
Yeah, like these were clean. Um and so
that's where it's like again, the you
know, I can always work on being more
patient, too, but if you can just be
more patient and be like, oh, this is a
spot, but I'm just not going to you
know, it's just not a good level. I'm
just going to wait. Um
you're you're probably going to be more
profitable. But again, it's it can be
hard cuz like here it's like there's so
much movement and you're not taking
trades and it sometimes it gets the
better of you, right?
Yeah. But so that's where this zone was.
I think or I was like looking at this
low here thinking like, okay, well, it
had this kind of bounce range. Um
And so that's kind of what this level
was here and so the market broke out of
that and came lower and we're actually
at a good timing. Like, you know, 9:30
market opens. It kind of just shot up,
which was a nice spike and then it just
went into this kind of trend.
And what made me like this was it had
kind of a spike up here in such a big
pullback Yeah.
>> of good momentum and kind of breaking
below this kind of chop it had. And so
my thinking is, you know, it's it's kind
of making that head and shoulders right
here where it makes a new low, pulls
back. I kind of see how the market
reacts to this pullback.
And then I think this, if it goes down,
you know, it opens the door to this.
Yeah, you're waiting for that
candlestick to close below the green one
and then you would get in? Yeah, I mean
I think
>> idea? Yeah, I think I was just watching
it but like the idea was, yeah, I put in
a stop order here
and then was going to see how cuz it's
like, okay, I think this is a good
enough attempt, especially this
candlestick right here. Like as it's
forming, I'm thinking, well, if it's
going to make a double bottom here, this
is probably the candle because it's
showing some strength right here and
attempts to go higher, that's probably
the candlestick that's going to do it.
But because that over this candlestick
that essentially fails, you know, then
it's like, okay, well, I think if it
breaks this, that's great to the
downside and you know, there's a little
bit of But real quick, would you not
want to wait for it to finish forming a
candle that is like at the end of this
candlestick get in
with a buy below it?
>> You can. I think sometimes without
having like a real good rule for each,
sometimes I'll wait and sometimes I
won't. I think often generally it's I'll
wait if it does like a big spike and I
want to see how it the market reacts to
that or if it's like, I'm a little
doubtful, I want to see how and I think
the market's just going to fake lower
and go higher. I'll see how it, you
know, essentially breaks this new low.
If it's just going to break it and
reverse. And like you said, I put a stop
or or my entry kind of below this
candlestick here.
But like if I if it already has done
like a pullback and I'm I'm confident
and kind of happy with where things are
at, then I'll just kind of get in at the
break of a new low cuz, you know, for me
like that's making a new low and that's
kind of confirming that this is a lower
high and the head and shoulders is in
play. Yeah. You know, I I thought it
opened the door up to down here. Um I do
think that my one thing was thinking,
okay, well, there is because this, you
know, this is where the unhealthy move
is. Before that, I think kind of here is
a potential support level.
Um and so
>> Just cuz it started being more calm
there. Yeah, cuz it was like this was a
healthy trend. Yeah.
>> And so my thought is, okay, well, it's
showing reversal signs up here. Maybe
we'll get a healthy trend down and if it
breaks this, like you can see I drew
that level. If it breaks that, then I
think we'll get the flush lower. Um so
that's where like a little bit of a risk
in entering this is compared to like if
if the head and shoulders happen right
here and you're able to get in short as
it breaks kind of this Yeah, yeah. Those
are the best trades because there's like
there's just nothing in the way and it
will just, you know, crater super fast.
Like those are when I get trades where
it's like it's over in like 5 minutes or
something and it's crazy. Yeah. Versus
here it's like you kind of got to let it
develop. Yeah. And so here it made this
little pullback and I thought, okay,
I'll move my stop down cuz it
essentially made a swing low. And then
here it's like, okay, I'm watching to
see if it does a double bottom. Um Mhm.
cuz it's
>> In which case you just slam it closed.
Yeah, or yeah.
>> down even more. Um yeah, and it I I mean
like this looks super good right here.
Like this
>> Yeah.
>> attempt to go higher, big bearish
candlestick and it's
>> thing. It's literally like it's made a
new low and it's basically breaking this
support, but it actually ends up, I
think, pretty much just here. Just And
so here it's tricky cuz like I don't
want to close out yet cuz like Yeah,
it's still looking
>> low and like this was a nice swing.
Sometimes it's like you just got to let
it do its thing. Like I've already taken
some risk off and I'm happy with this
level. Like it could totally spike here
and sell off. Yeah. And so, you know, I
made the conscious decision to be like,
"Okay, I'm happy with If I lose, you
know, 900 bucks, I'm happy with that. I
I think it was okay moving it my stop
from down from there." Cuz at this
point, if it does such if it makes new
high, I would just want to get out.
Like, it's probably going to continue
higher.
>> back up. Yeah. Um but, there's so many
times where like, you know, this if it's
going to go down like this high would
hold. Like, even if pulls back here and
then goes down. And so, that's why
>> you know, when it's it's like here and
it's starting to look, you know, I even
drew that little line and it's starting
to like make a spike up like this, I
don't close out of break even just with
the idea that, you know, it's like I
think the trade is still valid and it
could spike up and go lower. Like, you
just don't want to over manage.
Yeah, you got to have, you know, it's
like you can't I don't think you can
take the risk off until like it's down
in this area for this particular trade.
But, that's you know, that's like
something I'll just take time to get
better at. Yeah. Yeah, we got to get to
enter trades first. [laughter]
>> Yeah. Oh, that's really interesting
though. Yeah, I mean, I guess we could
we could do entering stuff and get you
kind of like schooled up on that.
>> Yeah, let's do some of that. I know I
still need to watch I don't know the
second part of your course that's more
aimed at I think entries and some
management.
>> Okay. So, I can at least watch some
entries part of it cuz I think you go
over it like
quickly in the first part and then
you're like, "I have more detailed
videos later." Yeah. Well, let me just
send you my indicators. My courses all
courses. Yeah, I don't have the
indicators unlocked on your website.
Okay, so we're we're just going to do
the three main ones. And for these
indicators, um
anyone else that wants them, you can
I'll leave a link for them in the
description below. Um you want to go to
to install them now, you want to go to
just your main control center and your
NinjaTrader main control center. Yep.
And then go to
tools, import, and then NinjaScript
add-on. And then that file you had
that's like a zip file, um you're going
to want to find out wherever that is.
Usually you want to save it somewhere.
Don't save it
for like PCs and stuff. Don't put it in
like your one drive folder.
Um,
just cuz that messes things up. You want
it locally stored on your computer and
then just double click and essentially
open the zip file with the import
option. I gave you kind of like a
special packaged one so I don't know if
that's going to work or not. If it
doesn't, we can do a different way. But
let me know when it's like says import
successful. Successfully imported. Just
right click on the chart and go to
indicators. Yep. And then do you see
this at the top? There's like a little
Evolve Traders file. I do. Okay and then
you should have the bar timer in there.
Yep. Double click that. That'll add it
to the chart. Just apply? Yep. Well, no,
just just Oh, just okay. Got it.
>> And then double click the click trader
as well. And I think that's kind of the
two you have there. Yeah. And then so
you should have those two and then just
the default settings is totally fine.
You don't have to do anything with them.
And then you can just click okay and you
should now have like this box on the
right side and then this little
countdown timer right next to your
candlesticks. Okay. I see the countdown
timer. I don't see the box. We also we
closed out of whatever the thing that
says like buy, sell, everything like
that.
>> Oh, so you just need to go up to here
and turn the chart trader back on. Okay.
Yeah, now I see. Okay, how it works
basically is if you hold shift and I'm
going to switch this to account so I
don't actually enter in an order. You
can click it like pretty much and then
left click on the chart, it'll put in an
order and then if you do control a buy
order and then if you do control, it'll
do sell.
Um,
settings that might mess that up for
you. I don't if you you see primary
order here and secondary order?
>> Yeah. Those you want to put as stock
market as your primary order and I like
to do MIT, which means market if
touched, as your secondary order. So,
market if touched is if it hits that, it
just trades. Yeah, so essentially if you
put a a market if touched buy order
below the price, if the market just
comes down here and touches that, yeah,
it'll put in a market order basically
that'll automatically buy at the best
available price. So, essentially the
idea with that is, okay, well, if I'm
putting this in and the market touches
here, I want to get in because it's at a
price I want. I don't care if it um
slips on me a tiny bit. And slippage is
like if you, you know, if the market's
moving so quickly, it'll fill you at a
price that you didn't necessarily enter
in. Like, this is the price this order
is at 6960.75
and if it slipped, it would enter in at
something else. Like, let's say, I'll
just move this for simplicity's sake,
but it like slips all the way up here to
61.50. Like, that would be a a worse
entry for a buy order cuz you originally
would be trying to buy down here. But,
that very rarely happens. Generally when
the market's like extremely volatile. Um
and actually, if you go to indicators
again, I would say you do want to try
and um if you click on the click trader
once you've changed that market if
touched button. Um
also, you can actually change the hot
keys on here. I if you don't want your
sell, like the hot key to trigger a sell
order, um you can change it from
control. Or if you don't want the um buy
order to be shift, you can change those
to other items or other hot keys. But,
for me shift and control just I find
works. And then of course, at the bottom
like just click on the template button
to save as your default. So, it always
has those. Is it then set up as on bar
close? Yeah, so that just allows you to
again, like, when, you know, like in
these trades, like when I say, okay,
well, I want to I see this candlestick
here, right? And my signal is that I
want to buy above this candlestick, I'll
just hold left shift and put a buy order
right there. So that as soon as it if it
does and as soon as it does reverse,
it'll get in an order exactly that
point. So I generally just get in on
stop orders. Okay, so shift and just
click. Shift and then left click, yeah,
with your mouse. It's not doing it. Do
you have an uh-oh, you need a okay, you
don't have an ATM. This I'm assuming
says none. Oh, yeah. Okay.
>> Sorry. Um you need to go and I think
your option will either be do this
drop-down menu and click custom and it
should bring this up. Okay. Um so you
don't need the order quantity doesn't
you don't have to mess with that. Change
the parameters to ticks and then your
stop loss and profit target, I just do
this to um like if I'm trading the the
ES generally, I'll just say, "Okay, I
want to my profit target to be let's say
um
I'll just put it in oh, just in that
points, okay." Um yeah, you can do this
like 60 here for a profit target and um
like 30 for a stop loss and then just
click okay. Actually, no, you want to
save the template. Um I'll just save it
as test. You don't really need to change
anything else. Okay, yeah, it should
work now. Okay. Um and then you can just
click so what if it's here, you can just
click buy market actually to test it. Um
and then you can see it'll pretty much
automatically put these orders for you
and that's what the stop loss and profit
is. You're essentially that number we
put in there is saying, "Okay, this is
going to be 30 ticks away from your
entry." I think the stop was 30 ticks
away and then this is going to be 60
ticks away. Okay, so that's setting your
essentially one to two. Yeah. And then
your your risk loss calculator does all
that for you, right? Yeah, we'll get
that into that in a second. Um
and so well, so I always try and have
these just far away cuz the idea is like
okay, yeah, we'll we'll talk about this
in a second is like I have the the risk
calculator all we have drawn and then
I'll just say okay, it's here
essentially like especially with these
is like I want them far away from the
actual price in a safe way cuz then you
know, it doesn't take long but you know,
a couple seconds to be like okay, here's
actually where I want my stop and then
here's actually where I want my target.
Oh, got it. Okay.
You know, I'll essentially move those.
Yeah, and then so just to kind of close
this out and then yeah, the next thing
is the is yeah, the risk reward
calculator
cuz this will automatically update how
your order quantity needs to do based on
your target amount. So first thing is
well just to see if it imported if you
go to drawing tools here, right click
and drawing tools. Do you see it right
here at the bottom?
>> Yeah, I do. Okay, so that will
essentially pull it up. Um
and I think first thing is actually if
you go back to your control center, we
want to go to tools and hot keys. Just
so then you can put I cuz I don't think
when we originally set up hot keys this
was available.
>> No. So if you scroll all the way down to
bottom, um it should be there now.
Perfect. Okay, and then from there do
you have this to draw up now risk reward
tool? Yep. Okay, and then double click
on it to bring up properties and then a
couple things I believe that the default
doesn't have on it is
um
you can set your risk here. So, you
know, when you're starting out demo
trading, I would always try and just do
like uh
let me see if I go to the MES right now,
which is what you would be trading
and let's say like you try and risk $50
a trade. Like I think that's a great
starting point. So like $50 a trade
definitely gives you some wiggle room.
Trade it if you're trading small enough
like if you were only trying to risk $20
a trade, sometimes you would be you
know, one contract would be too big.
Like here if if I was going to enter in
like this this morning, you know, we
were talking about this, like if I was
if this sold off here and I got in below
this, like and you're trying to only
risk $20, like it it would be too much.
But like with 50 bucks, like you're
you're much better There's more
flexibility. Same thing with like this
long down here. You know, you're it's
going to be Sometimes you're it's going
to be harder to get the right target
amount of risk, but that's just kind of
how it goes, especially when you're kind
of just starting out with sizing and and
you don't have the flexibility of
contracts. So, yeah, set your risk
currency to $50 here.
Um and then I usually have You want
strict risk clicked off. And then I
usually have unrestricted risk at like
10 or 15%. Um and what that does is it
allows your risk to go over whatever you
set. So, like you you set at $50 and
this is saying you can go 15% over that.
Um you know, with $50, it's not that's
not a crazy amount. It's like 650 or
whatever this is allowing you to do. Um
once it goes over that, it'll say, you
know, zero contracts. And then it will
be like, okay, you're over your risk
amount. You could always set that to be
a little more if you're like, "Hey, like
I want I want to get in a trade if it's
especially when you're trading crazy
small risk like this. If you're like,
okay, well, I want to take a trade if
it's like I'm fine taking a trade if
it's like 60 or $75 risk." Then you can
up this. But like once you get larger
size, I would definitely reduce that
down cuz you don't need to be going
crazy over your risk amount. This is a
dumb question. It doesn't want to let me
move it around very well. When you click
on it, I you have to I have to click on
this line to select it and then it
should have these little circles. Okay,
there we go. That's working better.
Yeah, I see the circles. Yeah, I I you
can't really select the colored lines.
You have to click on the gray line.
Okay. Um
I don't remember if this is the default
color settings either, but you can just
change them down here. Okay. What does
moving the circles around do? I mean, it
basically just remove moves where the
anchor is. Like, it's just kind of like
it it has kind of like a default size,
but it just helps like visualize
>> Visualize it. Okay.
>> like where you want and then obviously
like vertically changes
um
how it works. The last big thing is um
you want this this auto set quality is
always off by default. You need to click
that on and then that should be the last
setting. If you want to increase how
many profit targets you have, pretty
much you just have to do the same
grammar that it has set up here in this
little ratios box. You can literally
just copy paste and add a four. Okay. Um
and I think if anyone's on the European
or just non-American, it's slightly
different how it's set in there. Um
but you know, that adds you another
target if you want to see that. And then
of course, uh actually in there there's
also um you can change this to not have
essentially price or a dollar amount of
the risk. You can just change it to
price or something, but usually risk
reward the default setting works for me.
And then that auto set quality makes it
so this automatically updates like you
were saying. So like if if I you know,
one contract, it changes this. So like
if you then make it smaller, this
automatically updates to three, right?
So that you Got it. Okay.
>> It's super easy to say, "Okay, well, I'm
going to put my stop loss here and my
target here and if I'm trying to target
roughly $50 of risk on this trade based
on that size of a stop loss, how many
contracts do I trade?" Because when the
market moves, you know, and and where
that is like that changes. Like here
from here to here is $50. Um and you
don't want to just be trading two
contracts every time cuz down here it
actually takes three contracts to do
that same risk, right? So that's like
the huge thing about it that makes it so
easy to just use this and say, "Okay,
well, my risk is here, You know, it's
$50. I'm going to just put my my order
right here and with my shift click hot
key." And so, it makes entering in like
super fast.
So, these are like insanely big quality
of life upgrades, I would say. And then,
you know, with the hot key and the
default, you know, here's my mine
defaulted to my normal size. Then, you
switch over to the cuz we're on a micro,
you know, right now, you would switch
over to the normal size.
>> 4.5 or something? Yeah, it just it just
default to it cuz you can't trade half a
contract. It just default to four
contracts. Yeah. I mean, any other entry
questions? That's That should be pretty
much the main setup. I don't think so. I
think that's the That's the nuts and
bolts. It seems like it's just getting
better in understanding exactly what I'm
looking for Yeah.
>> of reversal patterns. Cuz I mean, like
so far, most of what we've been looking
at and what I've been looking at is the
like larger sets of candlesticks and
what they're all saying together. And
this is much more like, "Well, what is
this specific candlestick say and how
are these three candlesticks interacting
together?" Yeah. And
one thing I actually to bring back up
about the
drawing tool is visually what it does
very easily to mess with your mind is,
you know, like let's say for here,
right? The signal to jump in on this
trade was here and the stop would be
here cuz that's where the swing was. And
so, for this trade,
um you know, I would I would draw my
tool right here cuz this is, you know,
one tick below here and then I'd I'd
enter here, right? And so, you know,
it's it's targeting my risk. I I would,
you know, put my order in here and I'd
wait to get in. Okay, so you're putting
it You're putting it one The bottom is
one tick lower. Yeah. Yeah, technically,
I like to do it one tick below cuz I
like then that's officially broken that
low. Same thing with this high. It's
officially broken that high when it's
one tick above. Um
But so, the thing that can mess with
your mind is, you know, it's like,
"Okay, well, I'm going to get in on a
stop order here. But, if I enter in down
here, if I just enter in on a buy order,
a buy, you know, on a pullback, that
allows me to, you know, you would adjust
this down and you can start to say,
'Well, I would hit 3x right here. I can
get, you know, 10 more contracts.' You
know, like just the the ratio, like your
risk-reward ratio, you know, from
entering in here, you would be up 2x
when it's that that price versus if you
entered in here, you'd be up 3x. Uh
and so, it's very easy to like not get
in or instead of putting in that stop
order, you put in, um you know, a buy
limit order down here and wait for the
market to come back and fill you, if it
does. And you know, you run the risk of
it not coming back and filling you and
just shooting up. Or, I mean, in this
case, it broke up and then you'd wait
for a pullback, but sometimes if you
just wait for it to pull back versus
not, you know, you want to get in
essentially when the signal happens,
bottom line. Um
I'm sure there's ways to maximize things
in more ways, but like at the end of the
day, it's better to just get in with the
signal and you know, your your
maximizing is going to be sizing down
the road. Um
cuz like at the end of the day, the goal
is to just capture some of this move. Um
and even though at your current size,
it's like, "Well, I would be, you know,
up X amount here versus if I entered in
here, I would be up way less. You know,
I'd be up 2x instead of 3x." And it's
like, "Well, you're still up money and
you're getting in you're you know,
you're not trying to like I just had
times in the past where I'll try and
play with that and it just Again, it
just it just adds another layer of just
where you make mistakes and mess things
up. And then if you if you miss it and
you don't get in or whatever, like it
just messes with your mind and your
ability to just do clean executions.
Yeah, that makes sense. I think that's
all I have on entries unless you have
any other questions. I don't think so,
especially not for nuts and bolts. I
mean, the main thing is just trying to
figure out exactly what I'm looking for
in terms of patterns or trying to
understand the couple candlesticks that
go together. And some of that might be
But I think that a lot of that really
comes up when it's like you start
actually trading and it's like
you know, it's like you actually have to
make that decision of like, "Oh, I'm
going to enter in here." And even you
know, even when it's like demo trading,
it's like you're still taking that
making that decision versus just kind of
watching the candlesticks print.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Um well, I guess what
do you think my homework or thing to
focus on should be for the week? Just
playing with some of the risk-reward and
looking for spots and thinking more
about the entry and probably going
through some of your course.
>> Yeah, I mean, I think main homework for
this week would be I mean, you know,
obviously everything we've already done,
just continuously be
>> keep doing it. Just keep doing it.
>> You know, it's it's the whole thing is
just like building on itself. So, you're
always should be looking and thinking
about the main trend and like then, you
know, thinking about the patterns and
everything. But yeah, I mean, I think
the main addition this week is even if
you don't enter in a trade, like there's
no pressure to enter in a trade now that
you have the ability. It's more of like,
"Okay, just get used to like like you're
saying, the risk-reward tool and like
what that feels like." Even if it's like
you play around with just entering in a
trade, you know, uh during market hours,
but it's not necessarily a trade that
you're like, "Oh, this is, you know, a
this is a you know, following the
strategy." It's more of like you're just
entering in the trade. So, it's like
seeing what like moving this stuff
around and like Yeah. you know, what
like your risk-reward tool is saying and
just making sure all that's kind of just
getting good.
>> Even just playing with the risk-reward
tool to get an idea of what are the like
what are the different amounts look like
for Yeah. me risking X amount. Yeah, cuz
it's just adding another, you know,
Yeah, another layer. Yeah, cuz I think
it's like in in these first few weeks
it's so much in the beginning like it
just even if it's just adding something
that seems very simple like that it's
just, you know, adds this something else
that's completely new to think about and
that's why I think about it slowly is
important. Perfect. I'll send you this
guide and anyone else below can get it
below. It it's it's pretty
straightforward and basic but again like
this strategy straightforward and basic
it'll just help you remember like the
main things you're looking for and going
off of there. Coolio. Yeah, thank you so
much. This is super useful and helpful.